[Music]
the twins du Cheval was to France what
the Volkswagen Beetle was to Germany
mobility for the masses it was designed
in the 1930s to help French farmers who
still relied on horses and carts as our
classic car expert christoph bauer
explains he says citron boss Pierre
Bouchet had concrete ideas about the car
it should have room for two farmers and
a sack of potatoes and do at least 60
kilometres an hour yet have such a
comfortable suspension that a basket of
eggs could survive journeys over bumpy
fields unscathed it should be easy to
operate but looks weren't important in
1939 sat.1 began making prototypes of
the tpv as it was then called for toot
petit fuller or very small car though
not terribly attractive they met belong
J's criteria even passing the test with
a basket of eggs third designer Flamini
Alberto nee was told to keep the car
functional he was instructed to create
an umbrella on four wheels christophe
says that after the end of the second
world war Bertoni was allowed to gussy
up the body a little in 1948 the do
cheveux finally made its debut but
response was lukewarm the press dubbed
the car a sardine can
or even worse an ugly duckling Oh Lala
in Germany the name stuck to this day
the car is lovingly called tienta or the
duck these are spitzy from a dog
into good allah school in france the car
quickly became a favorite and why not
after all it was designed to meet the
wishes of the public as expressed in one
of the first big market surveys
conducted in 1922 then tire manufacture
missional asked 10,000 people what their
ideal car would look like christophe
says it'd be hard to build a more basic
car than the do cheveux
to him the seats resembled camping
chairs the windows don't roll down you
swing them out and hook them on here hmm
and you can hardly call this a dashboard
it's just a couple of pieces of sheet
metal that have been cobbled together
interestingly the main instrument here
is the battery indicator the speedometer
is stuck here in the corner strangely
enough the speedometer cable
simultaneously powers the windshield
wipers so if a rains hard you should put
your foot on the gas so I wanted a stick
ask him
cathodic huh fabulous Christophe says
the do cheveux is built on a box frame
on which all of the body parts are
mounted so like the VW Beetle it doesn't
employ unibody construction and as you
can tell from the protruding wings and
hood-mounted headlights it's old
fashioned design dates from the
pre-world war ii era but it's huge soft
top also makes it into a convertible
what sounds like a luxury was at the
time nothing but a cost-cutting measure
a sheet metal was in short supply in the
post-war he rocked in click of our start
list its demand Ibaka sat when never
tried to pass off its ugly duckling as a
beautiful swan its ads said the cars
shape was unusual but that it's
performance was second to none the
vehicles legendary suspension with its
longitudinal coil springs make the do
cheveux feel like no other on the road
the Spartan trunk can hold many sacks of
potatoes while the rollback canvas roof
puts in plenty of fresh air inside the
simplest of seats and the unfinished
looking cockpit complete the minimalist
look ta-dah Malta and Krista says under
the hood you'll find the two cylinder
425 CC box er engine with an output of
just 12 horsepower you can't get much
lower than that although the first
douche of OHS at just 9 horsepower yet
the engine was progressive for its time
to reduce weight the cylinder heads and
cylinder block were made entirely from
aluminum and he says it's the only car
he knows that you could start with a
crank that was still in production in
1990 said twin even considered doing
without an ignition switch in starter
motor the reason that it was a car for
farmers who all had wives to turn the
crank so much for equal opportunity
even the douche avos with the most
powerful engines have a hard time
breaking the 100 kilometer an hour
barrier going from 0 to 100 takes 30 to
40 seconds yet there's no time to get
bored
Christophe says the douche avos off-road
capabilities and hair-raising cornering
are legendary if you push it the card
tips so far to the side that you think
it's going to tip over but it doesn't
it's boxer engine makes for an extremely
low center of gravity so it's almost
impossible for the do cheveux to flip
over back in 1967 sits when considered
stopping production but the do cheveux
survived and continued to roll off the
assembly lines until 1988 in France and
1990 in Portugal in its later years the
models horsepower increased to 28 3
times as much as the original douche
avos Vigo Christoph says it's hard to
make a car with less the new shahboz
technology was extremely basic and it
cost almost nothing to run that turned
this anti status symbol into a
much-loved status symbol for students
anti-nuclear activists and
environmentalists more than 5 million
were built over four decades he feels
the do shovel symbolizes savoir view the
French Way of life like no other car
which makes it a true milestone in
automotive history it's low maintenance
costs and robust technology have made
this suit one an enduring classic
despite its small engine and minimal
cubic capacity some drivers have clocked
up 300,000 kilometers in their do
shallows not bad for an umbrella on four
wheels